I had a friend um I got into his car and
uh I I was talking to my father and I
said okay I Love You by he who was that
he I go that's my father he goes you say
you love you I love you to your father I
go yeah and he goes I would never do
that with my father and I go you gotta
do it you got Life's Too Short Man
Life's Too Short you got to do it was it
more difficult not to talk to your mom
or your dad during that period I was
real mad at both of them so
um but it was harder on my mom because
my mom was like a casualty kind of of it
she was still a fault but I look at it
her like casualty but it's like ni my
mom my mom's a real standby your man
type and I respected her for that but at
the same time it's like Mafia wife yeah
tell him he's wrong tell him talk we
don't know what you're talking about but
I apply pressure I apply pressure is
like talk to your guy you want to talk
to me talk to your guy talk to your
guy the Honeydew with Ryan sickler